what's going on
the magic is in danger we gotta get out
of here we must protect our home we must
protect our family
so encanto is an animated musical set in
colombia and it is about
this amazing family all of them have
these wonderful magical gifts with the
exception of the youngest granddaughter
mita bell and her story is about her
learning to see herself and her family
differently hi everybody i'm byron
howard one of the directors of encanto
which we'll be talking about today and
i'm jared bush another director of
encanto and co-writer and today we're
going to be looking at a clip towards
the end of the film which is mitabel at
her lowest moment where for the first
time she starts to understand her
grandmother abuela alma a little
differently and learns to understand the
choices that she has made over the
course of her life
all right so here we're with mita bell
at what's pretty much her lowest moment
the house has just fallen it's really
important to us that mirabelle blamed
herself for everything that's just
happened to have mirabelle take it so
hard to really see that as as her
singular failure we don't know how we're
going to ever come back from it so when
will alma steps in here she immediately
assumes that whale alma is there to
reprimand her to scold her
i'm sorry
it didn't would have hurt us
i just wanted
to be something
the sequence was a combination of many
different people myself included drawing
many many different versions of this
moment and i think we all really
in these story rooms we all get on the
same page emotionally like we all kind
of know what the target is and we had
talked about this scene for years during
uh the development of encanto because it
was really the most critical moment
between these two women
i've never been able
to come back here
this river
is where we were
given our miracle knowing that it's a
musical we spent a lot of time in this
moment
with what should it sound like we
dropped out music completely even the
environment sounds are low
muted colors we looked even like the
speed of the river we really wanted
things to feel very still and honestly
for there to be a little bit of
discomfort in how bald and how naked
this moment is
i thought we would have a different life
i thought
i would be a different woman
rarely ask voice actors to put on a
funny voice we really want people to be
those characters and to really relate to
those characters and for maria patero
she's colombian so she knows what this
moment is saying she knows about the
resilience and the pain and the strength
that this this moment requires and what
her own grandmother and grandfather went
through
[Music]
the non-songwriters you go like this
feels like it could be a musical moment
you know something we always talk about
is
why does there have to be a song there
usually it's because there's something
very emotional that's happening that a
character can't just say those things
they must be compelled to sing those
things once we have this sense of like
well maybe this is a song that a
character's not seeing where we're
hearing it it is that sort of it sounds
like an old folk song or it might sound
like this is a song that the spirit of
abuelo pedro is somehow singing a little
bit it started to make a lot of sense to
us
[Music]
the wonderful thing that happens during
this song is that it's all visual it has
a beautiful love story of this young
couple who had all the hope in the world
and things went very very differently
than they had expected the research that
our teams did on
materials like every loop of the that
embroidery and the fabric on the bed is
so beautifully researched every every
tile is is painted by some of my hands
so it's really these movies are handmade
[Music]
it's really critical for us to show the
youth of these characters before what
we're seeing now which is the tragedy of
their history starting to come into play
bringing in some of the history of
violence that many people in colombia
had faced
and that was very critical to them to
make sure that that was included in the
story there's an amazing amount of
dissonance the song's telling you that
it's not going in a great direction but
you're seeing something wonderful that
tells you like oh i'm starting to not
feel good and then you're seeing
things get worse and worse and then
extremely tragic as you're still hearing
a love song that combination is
something that i think really was the
efforts of every department firing on
all cylinders at their very best to
deliver something that is greater than
the sum of its parts
[Music]
when the miracle happened byron boarded
this the candle itself sort of exploded
with a a butterfly of flame came out of
the candle and it was this enormous
eight foot wide butterfly that
used its wings to blow
back the assailants that were coming on
their horses and it was this really
spectacular thing that was in our our
film for quite a long time because it
was so beautiful ultimately it felt like
okay well it's that's a a wonderful
moment but we needed to simplify the
neat thing was we then had this
butterfly imagery that was already in
our head so as lynne went to write the
song in his mind you know the greatest
miracle of nature which is that
transformation from caterpillar to
butterfly sometimes these pieces come in
and out but they can inform you in a way
that leads you down a path you never
could have gotten to had you not done
the early work even though that early
work changes alma decides that she has
to leave this pain behind and push it
down
and become someone else and this is i
think mirabelle actually seeing that in
her grandmother and seeing her journey
it's a fantasy space and we do play a
lot with staying true to emotionally
what's going on but you know it is a bit
of a risk right we're changing the
dimensions of the house that's kind of
weird we're doing the doors are not in
the order that you've seen them in
throughout the course of the movie but
emotionally it felt right but those are
risks you take hoping that the audience
will go with you on that journey and
then you're also watching her age and we
didn't want her age to feel extreme
again we wanted this all to feel very
lyrical and soft as you're watching it
so that you're just really tracking the
emotion through all this leading to this
moment where she gets to young mita
belle in the moment where she didn't get
a gift and this is the first time we see
this reaction from a boil animal where
she's realizing how old she let mita
belt down how she should have been there
to comfort her and how she she really
lost her way
[Music]
abuela
i can finally see
so coming out of the song we talked a
lot about what mirabelle was feeling in
that moment and what what she would say
and you know i i love that it's sort of
wordless i don't think she knows what
she what to say to her grandmother and i
love this part so so much you know i
think this is an area where we start to
lean into jermaine franco's beautiful
score where you're hearing the encanto
theme the theme of the miracle and it's
the miracle theme is happening as
mirabelle is reacting with empathy and
she's seeing her grandmother for the
first time i love how beautifully subtle
the acting is and these even like the
tiny little things like how how much uh
the tears are showing up in their in
their eyes you know it's easy to go too
far but i just think when i when i saw
this coming in that was being animated
i believe in these people like i believe
that we're watching real people with
real souls and it's such a magnificent
um emotional moment for me i think
andrew ford animated this this moment if
i'm not mistaken he animated both sides
so both characters having this
conversation
and didn't worry about cam replacement
yet so often in animation you're with
the character that's speaking but we
wanted to be with a character that was
feeling and to see that that emotion
hitting her face
and so after we actually had the
performance then we chose
who to be
uh on camera for what part of that
we knew we were driving to this moment
we knew
that the sun was gonna come out they
would be in the middle of this river and
that they would be surrounded by
butterflies and we spent a ton of time
figuring out how many butterflies did we
need and we kept on adding literally
hundreds more and hundreds more and what
are they doing and what's the
murmuration look like and does it head
back does it not head back but i think i
remember every single time we saw it we
were like double the butterflies and
then we saw them again like this is way
too many we're like nope double it again
it's not just
an effect to put butterflies in the air
but to kind of how do you support that
and make it feel like this extraordinary
extraordinary moan it's also in the
middle of the canelo cristales which is
this amazing real river in colombia that
is literally what it looks like if you
went there that is exactly right and
that's something that i think a lot of
people
from colombia who know it were like i
know exactly what that is and hopefully
people that watch the movie want to then
go experience that for themselves
discovering that this thing that looks
so fantastical is a real place i've seen
this scene for more than two years and i
still get emotional watching it i think
just seeing that everyone who touched
the scene did such an amazing job and i
think brought their own emotion to it so
it's a huge compliment to our our
filmmaking team and uh just a wonderful
song too i just absolutely love this
song for me i have a really hard time
separating that journey of creating it
and the journey of mita bell and abuela
alma who emotionally are coming together
i don't know that i'll ever be able to
separate it but i do love
seeing people that have watched this and
it's emotional to a lot of people is
because i think it really resonates for
them as well
you